[Music]
alright guys we're live on the YouTube
and joining me today is a youtuber who
has done pretty much the scariest thing
that one person can do she has come out
as conservative the scariest of all
words Candice Owens aka red pill black
well thank you I'm so happy to be here
right now I am very happy excited to
have you here should I be calling you
Candice or red pill black how are we
gonna do this I guess people are calling
me but real black so either or you can
call me Candice yeah yeah you said you
were just walking down the street some
of that yeah red pill black I'm like I'm
Candice but I'm glad it's catching I
like red pill Aqsa so before you were a
youtuber which you're actually pretty
new to you you went by Candice I went by
Candice yeah alright well I feel like
we're gonna be on the level so I'm gonna
go with Candice yeah so you uh you have
a crazy story an interesting evolution
you suddenly caught fire and you're
doing pieces all over the place around
the Daily wire this morning I saw you on
Jesse Watters was it this past weekend
right a couple days ago so a clip of
that you're bouncing around you're
making moves
who is this Candice person alright let's
just do some history for the people that
don't know about you at all
I am honestly I'm just I'm just a girl
that makes videos the history as I grew
up in Stamford Connecticut I went to
school at the University of Rhode Island
pursued a degree in journalism which is
quite ironic yes yeah absolutely
um after college I was in a lot of
student loan debt you know I came from a
family doesn't have any money whatsoever
and I had to just pay it back so the
smartest move for me was to go into
finance I hit the ground running in New
York City worked in a private equity
firm for four years left that firm and
wanted to do my own anti-bullying
startup thing that went really sideways
when the left tried to do hit pieces on
me during the election and that was my
red pill moment really wait how did
doing an anti-bullying thing get you
caught up so I don't know if many people
that watch this show are familiar with
the gamergate scandal I certainly wasn't
I think most of my orders is familiar
like nobody fully gets it yeah
but feel free to take us down that road
for a little bit yeah so long story
short that whole scandal is built on a
girl named Zoe Quinn who says that she
was attacked by anonymous white men on
the Internet
and people were saying that that wasn't
true and she said that it was and
anonymous how did she know their skin
girl if you read the pieces that's
fascinating and you know yeah so I was
doing an anti-bullying startup that I
was really passionate about and I got a
phone call from her and I put up a
basically a three minute video on
Kickstarter teasing what we were gonna
do and I sent this one sentence which
was a figure of speech that I think set
the alarms off I said what we're doing
is figuratively lifting the masks up off
of trolls at the time she was working at
Twitter she was working for Twitter for
something called crash override network
and I immediately received an inbox from
her on Twitter saying she liked to talk
to me about and try to convince me that
the project that I'm doing is bad which
is very interesting but she calls me up
and I have no idea who she is I don't
know what gamergate is I don't know what
doxxing means and she says you have to
pull your project because people
actually don't want to find out who
harassed them she said I'm a victim but
I never want to know who harassed me on
internet like she was basically arguing
a point that didn't make sense if she
was actually harassed on the internet
that obviously my technology would be a
god saying as they never figured out who
harassed her and I said you know I
appreciate the phone call this isn't
really making sense to me you know it
sounds literally the reverse what you'd
think she would have called you to say
absolutely like she should have been on
board with what I was doing so totally
appreciate the phone call but I'm not
gonna pull my Kickstarter and she
started crying and she said if you don't
it's going to ruin everything and she
told me that she spends time on 4chan
because of what she does and she saw
that people were already talking about
my project and if I didn't pull it they
these anonymous white men and Trump
supporters the other member this was
during the election cycle yeah we're
going to come after me and Doc's my
family which essentially means
put up their personal information so
people can try to kill them that's what
she says so she said this is what they
are going she was oddly threatening you
with being Doc's but it wasn't she she
thought I was a total [ __ ] I think you
know and I'm like okay I'm not pulling
my project she hangs up the phone crying
within two hours we were absolutely
inundated about 4,000 emails via
Kickstarter like you know [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] die die die you know pull your
project and they have these super
obvious screen names like you know Trump
or die from 2020 white man behind
computer so I'm like is she kidding all
men by the way everyone was like you
know Dave at you know Bob at no woman
and magically everything that she tried
to warn me about came true within a
couple of hours of me refusing to pull
my project so I tweet very quickly again
not really knowing the bread and butter
of the gamergate scan though I said all
I can say is that 100% after speaking
with Zoe Quinn this girl was never
harassed she's doing the harassing and
the next morning I woke up The Guardian
The Washington Post and New York
Magazine were all calling me I was in
nobody with a Kickstarter that was three
minutes long Kickstarter pulled my
project and the next day big media and
in my head I'm thinking you know you
know journalism major Washington Post
amazing like you know at that point I
considered myself a liberal Democrat if
you will and so I was like great I'm
gonna talk to that I'm gonna tell them
about this girl you're gonna write the
piece you know about what bad feeling
where this is about to go this is about
to go completely sideways okay so I
speak to a person named Jessie single he
works for New York magazine and he's
like yeah I saw your tweet not a fan of
mine no yeah well he is a journalist
journalist hit man as I like to call
them and he speaks music yeah I saw your
tweet I just want to speak about what
happened you know super nice yeah and I
I tell him everything I'm like yeah you
know Zoey called me up open-and-shut
case obviously she told me to pull my
project I didn't and then I got harassed
he instead writes this article the tone
of it was a
essentially trying to Gaslight me oh you
know she seemed like a nice girl but she
got dragged into this conspiracy theory
Zoey actually is a girl that was
harassed you know and at that point I
realized oh my god like the media is
going to try to kill my project and
these journalists are absolutely lying
so The Washington Post called me and I
had the good sense to actually record it
I just turned on my camera and said
something something fishy's here and
this girl was obvious this girl Caitlyn
Dewey was asking me questions and she
was trying to figure out who was funding
us and her her job or her role was to
cough the funding cut off the legs of
Social autopsies who could never see the
light of day and she started calming
around so I actually got a tip but she
had already written the article and she
wasn't gonna try to smear me and I
essentially went back and forth with the
Washington Post I had caught her in a
live via email versus what she said on
the phone and they pulled the article
last second and told me I wasn't
important enough to run it anyways when
I threatened to sue them Wow yeah all
right wait there's so much here and it's
so related to everything and we haven't
even fully got to medical awakening yeah
so first off I love that you said
they're their hit man yes journalist
removalists yeah because the phrase I
mentioned it to you right before we
started I've been saying they're
activists not journalists but they're
hitmen absolutely it's what they really
are there's so many examples of this
that guy you mentioned it's not even
worth mentioning his name again
yeah he's attacked me on Twitter for
nonsense and it's just all it's like you
guys you're not even pretending no they
are hired and peed the higher-ups
definitely know about it they are hired
to take people out and to take
businesses out that you know are a
threat to them for some reason and my
threat was that they actually thought
that I had created a technology that was
going to unmask trolls imagine what that
would have done in the heat of the
election Hillary Clinton had millions of
followers on Twitter what if I actually
create something and said actually
that's all coming from that's like
that's like one person they've created
all these accounts you know she's
actually not winning this election what
if I found out on Twitter that the
person that was writing black lives
matter saying die die die [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] was actually someone that worked
in Hillary's campaign to create this
environment so they were actually
terrified that I created something okay
that was going to ruin everything
so wait a minute so did you actually
create
right so that's the thing so you didn't
even create this technology it actually
done their job as yours and asked me
questions about what I had created yes
they would have left me alone but I
think Kickstarter pulled it they pulled
it didn't give me a reason they just
pulled the project off an anti-bullying
it could you do anything that's more
innocent and more PG and anti-bullying
and we're raising money want to try out
this you know anti-bullying tech startup
type they mean nothing but a splash page
at that point yeah all right so you know
it's funny because hearing this it all
sounds incredible and yet I've
personally been part of some of the
stuff I've obviously sat across from
people from Brett Weinstein and Colin
Moriarty people that have been through
this monster right this dishonest media
the craziness online all of this stuff's
okay so this is all happening to you
when did you start piecing it together
instantly the second the Washington Post
called me and Kaitlyn Dewey was trying
to cut off the leads in the funding I
realized what I had to go back and watch
the Kickstarter and say what did I say
that set this off and I realized it was
that one line they thought that I
actually and then her saying you're
gonna ruin everything I piece it all
together instantly and I realized that
my friends were my enemies and my
enemies are my friends and the only
people that wrote covered the story
extensively and accurately or the white
nationalist Breitbart all right white
racists covered a black girl who was
trying to do a tech startup being
attacked by the media it's so
interesting that she used the word
everything you're gonna ruin everything
that's a really fascinating little play
and you know how sometimes a one word
can actually change everything you can
change everything yeah one word but
you're gonna ruin everything like I
think that in her line of work and with
all these people you they're always
complaining about these trolls yeah you
would have been handing them the golden
ticket right and I am convinced it's
because they are running essentially an
anti marketing firm right so they get
people to go online and they can build
people up or take them down or they can
get people fired up by pretending that
they're white men you know and during
the election cycle that was needed man
you know some of this it's like I try to
deal with things in the most sort
real-world way possible and yet there's
a conspiracy element to this right like
and I'm sure you were dealing with that
wait how far do I want to go down this
way
where does this lead fine but yet I see
world real world examples this all the
time like every now and again I'll tweet
something that might be remotely
controversial or it's usually a joke
that someone just takes the wrong way
but then I'll see someone will tell me
to like go [ __ ] myself or something and
then I'll look and it'll have 50 likes
the the response now none of those
people follow me they're all anonymous
accounts right and all and it's like how
did you even see that right in the first
it's not even how Twitter works right so
we know that there is some shady [ __ ]
here it's like how do we piece all of
this together I think she was working
with Twitter at that time like she was
running the anti harassment
chapter at Twitter called crash override
network so I really Twitter contacted me
yeah yeah okay okay so now you're waking
up to this yeah you you realize it
pretty quickly which is actually your
great credit to you I think so I think a
lot of people kind of see it and then
you either get scared or you're like no
no I must be doing something wrong or
whatever okay so you wake up to all this
how did this then how quickly did that
jump to the way you thought about
politics instantly I mean I was I became
a conservative overnight you know I
realized that liberals were actually the
racist that were liberals were actually
the trolls and then at the very same
time you have to remember this is April
2016 Trump is on the screen saying that
the media is lying but CNN is fake that
all of this you know it all began to
resonate with me because I realized that
everything he was saying was true so I
no longer bought into this idea when
they you know they were calling him a
racist or rapist or white nationalist
everything I bought none of it because I
knew that the media hired hitmen and
they were doing the most ridiculous hit
job on Donald Trump from start to finish
of his campaign yeah all right so I want
to put you up aside for a second but we
will get back to Trump but I'm just
completely fascinated by your story so
okay so you get this now about the media
right right but did it so what change
with you within you politically when you
say you went from being a liberal to a
conservative like did you change on
economics or on abortion or weed or gay
marriage or you know when I think back
on it I just I don't even know that I
ever really was a liberal I would I
didn't care about politics yes you ever
think about this I'm just a girl I was
trying to pay back my
student loans I wasn't involved in
politics I didn't really know what being
a liberal meant well being conservative
met I think at the end of the day I was
always a conservative I'm pretty
rational I'm very fact-based in terms of
I will always value like you know
economics above like social issues and
that sort of thing as I understand that
that should take a backseat obviously I
mean you don't have a third world
country you know screaming about yeah
exactly so I think I was always a
conservative or more conservative in
that regard but I started really deeply
considering politics my positions on
everything because of that experience
yeah where are you on the social stuff I
think I'm what specifically what well
like a marriage
oh I support gay marriage yeah I support
gay marriage I'm not really sure about
abortion I don't really have a position
on that just yet I think through that
Allah I just have I have so many people
and friends that have been through it
Wow look at you a conservative saying I
don't have an answer on that yeah I
don't know I thought you guys are all
supposed to be yeah rush to judgment
yeah I'm open and I make it very clear
to everyone that I'm still learning I'm
still developing I don't want to be one
of these people that's just a number
Ten's I know every I that I know
absolutely everything because I think
that that's the problem in the world
right now is that everyone is pretending
to know everything and people aren't
willing to learn and if I can go from
someone who thought that they were on
the left to someone who is I think more
centrist and more conservative in a
matter of 365 days then it's would do me
a lot you know a lot of good to continue
to keep listening and continue to keep
growing yeah I like the emphasis on
listening there that's yeah as I said
it's refreshing and it's real yeah
that's the thing so ok so all this
happens now you did a hilarious video
about what it was like to come out to
your parents but when you started
talking about this stuff publicly or did
you have a little period first where you
were talking about it privately before
you started doing that tube thing yeah I
mean as you mentioned it really was a
very scary thing to go through and it
was terrifying and you have to member I
was a private citizen then so when media
does hit peace on you and you're a
private citizen that can ruin your
entire life you know you can't go out
and get jobs anymore because they
naturally believe whatever they read it
seems a incredibly controversial and
people don't want to deal with
traversée so I literally took a year off
which is kind of rebuild as a person
like I was like shell-shocked and I knew
that I wanted to enter in and I had to I
felt like it was incumbent upon me that
I understood this you know this
fascinating thing happened to me I felt
like it happened to me for a reason so I
wanted to sort of re-enter the market as
someone who was more informed and who
could potentially red pill other people
yeah and then alright so what happened
like so you tell your parents yeah the
video you did is great by like what kind
of reaction yeah you know I really
didn't sit them down and tell them I've
always been kind of a wild child as my
parents I've always had my own mind my
own thoughts I've never been a person
that like my parents would expect to
have to sit them down and tell them I
think I do what I want to do you know
what I mean yeah but what was
fascinating is the reaction you get
thinking more conservatively with your
friends right your liberal friends they
have no tolerance they have no tolerance
if you don't start if you don't sit the
liberal kool-aid and they're aggressive
and they're mean and they can say nasty
things and suddenly hit them with a fact
and they're under attack you know so
there was also a natural shedding of my
friends because I couldn't bear to be
around you know people that were
constantly in the state of victimhood
who didn't want to exchange ideas whose
you know if you think that then you're
perpetuating rape culture I'm like what
because I don't think Brock the judge of
Brock Turner's case should get death
threats I'm now the perpetuator rape
culture that's really aggressive right
yeah what about the type of things that
that they were saying to you based
purely on your race which no yeah yeah
instantly if you are an african-american
or you should black person whatever you
want to call it and you think
conservatively you're instantly
considered a traitor and Uncle Tom a
[ __ ] and don't want to hear anything
that you have to say so how's the
territory I mentioned this you right
before we started but I'm just gonna
repeat it real quick because I think
it's worthy of repeating but my friend
David Webb who is a serious XM guy and a
Fox News contributor the moment I
realized how actually truly racist not
just the word racist but truly racist so
much of the left was
was I was on air at the Young Turks and
one of the hosts we were watching a Fox
News clip and one of the hosts was
talking about David Webb and saying you
know what a token black guy he is and I
remember thinking I know him I just had
dinner with him two weeks ago this guy
believes what he believes that's racist
right what you just said is racist
because you look at a black man and
think if he doesn't think the way you
want him to that he's a token that this
is the essence of prejudiced prejudging
right and people can't they can't take
that and apply it somewhere else like if
someone said to you hey because you're
black you must listen to hip-hop music
and wear your pants low you'd say hey
that's ridiculous you know you're
stereotyping that's racist but if
someone says to you hey you're black so
you you know you should be a Democrat
they don't apply that that's the exact
seeing sort of racism yeah yeah yeah
yeah well it's a phrase that Bill Maher
used to say a lot but originally is from
george w bush which is the soft bigotry
of low expectations and lessly
patronizing yeah yeah absolutely it is
and you know the most refreshing thing
in the entire world is that there are a
lot of black people that reach out to me
on Facebook and say thank you so much
I'm finally feel like I can come out and
say that you know I disagree with the
way that things are going that's the
point of me doing all of this is to give
black people - Arion power them to not
be afraid that you're suddenly gonna get
your black card taken away you know
because you think differently and to
really challenge them to think as
independence how much is it that that
you think that there are other black
people out there that are afraid to deal
with what you're dealing with right now
because I see that I get emails all the
time from lefties I don't even know what
color or race they are it doesn't even
matter but just saying you know if I
started talking about this [ __ ] I'm
gonna get in a lot of trouble right
I don't know cursing a lot right yeah I
don't know why but if there's something
about your story that strikes me is so
like yeah just in what's happening right
now that yeah remember now but but that
concept though of I get it I get it from
these people saying I'm afraid I'm
afraid but I never thought of it
specifically within the lens of the
black community of like that they're
gonna take away my black car yeah it's
ridiculous they can get your black car
taken away that's impossible these are
our stories this is my history this is
my grandfather who you know was raised
on a share
cropping farm he's the one who raised me
who was branded in the face by the KKK I
know what real racism is okay and the
first thing they do is they threaten to
take away your black card and that to me
is something like who taught you to hate
your own race when they accomplished
something when they do something
differently I don't know where that came
from the psychology of that has always
fascinated me because they use these
terms like [ __ ] like Uncle Tom who
taught them those words who taught them
to be so nasty towards someone of their
own race and their own kind to hate
difference in their community yeah so
it's it's it's really interesting it's
fascinating and I always say I identify
as black but black is not I don't think
that because I'm black I have to think a
certain way you know what I mean mm-hmm
there's an odd position here also
because in a weird way if you if you
just happen to be white and you were
saying these things then in a certain
way you probably get a little less
traction in this right which is a weird
it's a reverse of identity it's a
reverse of identity politics and I know
neither one of us want to play those
names but it's even with me
I don't being gay is it's irrelevant in
the scheme of things but every now and
again I do use it to throw it in their
face right like oh actually maybe you
guys are the homophobe say if if gay
people have to bow to everything right
really gay people I you guys have a
whole nother set of issues that I
definitely need to be addressed because
I'm telling you they're forcing you back
into the closet they're looping you in
with issues only don't even make sense
right like why the hell should a gay
person have this like LBGT how many
letters are they gonna stick on them I
mean like one is just who you're
attracted to being trans has nothing to
do with being gay or lesbian you know
but they make you that's the brain wash
that's the groupthink well if you we
gave you gay marriage so now you better
help trans people get into the military
what yeah how did I get here well I
always think that like I have no more
inherent knowledge of what it's like to
be trans than a straight person or
anyone else right okay I was born in the
right body right I can't that sounds
probably you know that to me that I say
it all the time being trans that's a
mental disorder right that's a mental
you're mental in your physical aren't
mad
up the hell's have to do with we want to
sleep with yeah that's what being gayest
you know so it's interesting to see that
they constantly are trying to group
people into like these these things I
don't even make sense and tell me if
they have to start lead offend this you
know did you see I mean this
intersectional road to hell that's what
it is yeah when they when they latch
together did you see that in
Philadelphia at the gay pride parade
they made they took the rainbow and then
they had to put a black and brown bar on
it to represent communities of color or
whatever it is and it's like wait a
minute the rainbow had nothing to do
with race it was a wide we welcome
everybody regards was you guys now yeah
the ones that made this about race 1000%
yeah it's fascinating to watch that
people don't realize it and gay people
are being used like pawns right now the
high well I do the models do you see
that in a lot of other minority
communities in general because I see a
split now in the gay community kind of
waking up to this stuff I see it in the
black community now I see it in the
Jewish community I see it in the Asian
community right because they really need
to get rid of the Asians that's the next
one because Asians work hard are very
successful thank you economically but
they're a minority we can't have a
successful man right so they're they're
coming for the Asians I've started to
see you lately and I think that's just
gonna be ramped up yep absolutely
man we got our work cut out so then you
put videos on YouTube your channel has
blown up real quick I mean you got over
a hundred thousand subscribers and
pretty much a matter in no time yeah I
said you know suddenly I always say like
I end up with guests because suddenly on
Twitter there'll be like something kind
of bubbling and I'll be like I should
probably know who that is right and you
were like he was like suddenly out of
nowhere every day people are like you
got a dog there you gotta fight oh
somebody tweeted me this morning they
were like people want credit for it but
so you put the videos on were you
shocked how quickly they absolutely
shocked absolutely shocked and more than
just it blowing up here I was shocked to
see that they were dubbing these videos
I have like a french base of you know I
have like people in France are dubbing
all of my videos in French that people
can understand them people in Brazil are
double that dubbing them in Portuguese
so I was talking about something that I
thought was sort of unique to America
yeah but I'm realizing that I've hit an
international nerve when I talk about
the media and how the media you know
affects our psychology so that was
something that I wasn't expecting at all
whatsoever
so now you've sort of been embraced by
the conservative crew as I run waters
you did daily wire you met with the
Praeger guys blah blah blah so you're
doing all that are you are you meeting a
lot of scary races no I haven't it's so
weird
these white nationalists are really bad
at their job really bad at it you know
so so what would you say to the average
person that might say well wait a minute
the racism that exists or something like
that
like diminishing the word racist it's a
joke now it's a joke everything's racist
just because somebody thinks differently
than you does not make them a racist
okay and when you continually keep
calling people racist what you're
actually doing is diminishing the
experiences that real people that lived
through errors like that actually had
yeah so in it's upsetting it really is
because the civil rights era was
meaningful classic liberalism was
meaningful
you know these things we do need you
know liberalism in that regard right
when something actually happens that you
need people to step up to the plate and
say this is wrong we need classic
liberalism yeah should I do the cell job
on classical or you just went you just
skipped over you went right to
conservative but we could probably work
it's been hacked and it's so many of
these movements they try to dress it up
and you know and you know we branded
this as liberalism no it's not this is
fascism yeah you're saying that people
have to think a certain way because of
the color of their skin okay that is
absolute racism in my opinion to say
that I I can't think anything else then
this or that because of the color of my
skin that's absurd
it's absolutely absurd you can't think
this or that because you're gay you have
to always vote this way because you're
gay you have to vote this way because
you're a woman
Hillary went a campaign on being a woman
yeah did you see the thing with
yesterday I think it was Michelle Obama
saying it was the women that voted
against Hillary voted against their own
interest it's like stop stop us they
don't stop though they don't III hate
feminism so you can't even get me
started on that route and I mean they
don't stop they just keep tripling
tripling down doubling down quadrupling
down like they're just like we're just
gonna keep doing the same thing and see
if it works
it didn't work okay it
it's not working people are getting sick
of it people are getting pissed off and
people are abandoning liberalism so how
does this stuff link to the feminism
thing because I know some people watch
that - hey I hate feminism feminism what
is that what is how is this all linked
into fences because that that's one of
the pieces that I think people can't
quite figure out how did this thing get
so corrupted because yeah it's
absolutely corrupted that Swiper is
corrupted its radicalized feminism you
know used to like it again used to be a
classical liberal thing right it used to
be about we actually do not have the
right to vote when this when it was
first born in the 19th century was
actually about women needing the right
to vote about women's suffrage what
don't women have that men have now can
you answer that question for me I was
trying to think the same funny here
other than like you know different body
parts what are the opportunities that
are going to that would be offensive
yeah right yeah I know see me right it's
it's unbelievable and so they
radicalized it and again it's another
form of identity politics you are women
so you have to think this way you have
to think that way you have to vote for
Hillary who was the worst candidate ever
right there's so many issues that I have
with beyond Hillary her husband okay if
we want to talk about real issues in the
black community let's talk about the
crime bill you know that he put in place
and all the black people that he put
behind prison you know behind prison
bars he actually ruined an entire
generation of black families and that's
sort of like which larry elder spoke to
you about that's where everything when
our families got deconstructed in the
black community that's when everything
went sideways for us okay and instead
we're talking about you know BS is stuff
that's actually not going on in the
black community like black lives matter
and feminism is exactly the same exact
thing that's happening they're talking
about issues that aren't really
happening in the women's community and
they actually don't embrace woman okay
if they think differently but God forbid
a woman actually aspires to stay at home
and raise her children that's not an
easy job to raise you know three you
know for children to be good citizens in
the world that's something that woman
should be proud of and embracing but
they want you to say oh if that's what
you aspire to then it's because you're a
victim you know your husband made you do
this there are people that are happy in
those sorts of systems I don't want to
be a man also you know like this idea
that more men are equal
no we're not well men are not equal
there are differences you know we have
different hormones going through our
body we're different people and that's
totally fine you can't have a baby I
can't have a baby we're not the same
okay right we're just not the same so
it's it's been increasingly radicalized
and if you weren't done with it by the
end of Hillary's campaign I mean it's
just she really took it to the next
level yeah it's so but but this is what
intersectionality is all about it's
we're watching all of these fake
nonsensical things that got everyone
ginned up we're just watching them
crumble in front of us right which i
think is why there's so much craziness
right now so how do you approach you
know when when I'll talk to Larry elder
or some other conservatives about this
that it's actually the Democratic
policies that have harmed the black
community absolutely that seems like one
of those topics that the second you even
go a little there you just get an
unhinged amount of hate there the reason
that biggest I think the biggest problem
that we have in the african-american
unity is that we're actually not
educated about our history whatsoever a
lot of people don't know their own
history all they know is that they turn
on CNN and CNN tells them to look at
this look at that to be afraid of this
or to be afraid of that and they don't
know these things that larry elder talks
about right which is why to me the way
that i want to approach it is I plan on
getting in the faces of these movements
because I think that the indoctrination
the brainwash happens somewhere in on
college campuses you know that's where
people start to think I'm a liberal
mystic what I should care about this is
why I should not care about and the
issue that the conservative community is
having right now in my estimation is
that all of the you know major Charlie
Kirk my Logan Apple it Napoles who else
is going out and speaking on college
campuses right now well Shapiro
yeah Shapiro they go out to his college
campuses and Coulter and they speak to
conservatives mm-hmm oh that's not good
echo chamber right oh I want to go out I
want to speak to liberals I want to go
out I want to speak to black people you
know I don't love getting advice I don't
get invited by the liberal yeah I get
invited by libertarians and
conservatives
you're okay with all my liberal cred
right yeah
hope you do yeah and that's where I
think that I can make the most
difference is that I really want to
speak to them and just level with them
this isn't about name-calling which
tends to only happen you know if you're
on the right comes from the left isn't
about name-calling this isn't about
trying to you know say I'm right and
you're wrong or that you know I'm smart
and you're stupid it's really about
trying to level with them and get them
to understand where their ideas came
from because at a certain point I was
brainwashed too so I understand and I
get it I get what we think it starts
beyond that it starts in public school
you know like it's just where we're
taught to be liberals we really are yeah
it's interesting because I think usually
when people have this awakening there's
like sort of like a subtlety to it or
like it takes a little time it's very
obvious to me yours was just like BAM
yeah like it just like smacked you in
the face like a truck hit yeah yeah yeah
then you just ran with it where I think
a lot of people there's and maybe this
is a function of a little bit I'm gonna
use a little identity policy or maybe
it's a little bit of white guilt yeah
that the average white person that's
waking up to some of this stuff has been
so guilted right for so long to buy it
right but for you it you're like it's
it's me and my family and for the white
people they're just as guilty right
right right
why kill that's fascinating the people
that are still liberals and they refuse
to accept that I don't consider myself a
victim like they need to be the
superheroes you know yeah like you are
here you are a victim or you're a black
white supremacist which is like the you
know the Chelsea Handler recently I mean
that I mean that pissed me off to no
height the idea that she they're so far
gone leftist they're so delusional that
we've now gotten to a point where
Chelsea Handler a limousine liberal
right a limousine liberal thinks it's
acceptable to start revoking black cards
you know what I'll put it out right here
here I'm gonna talk to the camera person
I'll put it out right here Chelsea
Handler you are a hundred percent
welcome to come on this show you later
oh one phone to call a debate yeah have
a foundation with me will have a
conversation with you I would be glad
are we more than glad to do it and you
know what I will donate all the proceeds
what you got a charity election we let
her pick the charity yeah a cycling to
end father absences a father absence
charity we will donate all the proceeds
yeah
if she will do it I know you know what
we'll donate all the proceeds and I'll
throw in a thousand bucks over there
thank you I would love that
I'd love that yeah I somehow I suspect
she's probably not gonna buy it on this
Yeah right
only a conversation I really yeah it's
not about yeah it's not okay what she
did is not okay and I was I was so upset
about because like I said these are our
stories right like I grew up around
dinner table where my grandfather told
me what it was like to grow up in a
segregated south okay well my
grandfather told me you know what it was
like for him when he had to when he was
five years old get up at 4:00 a.m. in
the morning before it was too hot to lay
out tobacco on a sharecropping farm the
idea that she thinks that she can look
me in the face or look any black person
in the face without knowing their
history without knowing anything about
them and saying well because you think
like a conservative you're no longer
black it's the greatest insult ever like
I was I was fuming when I heard that I'm
I'm not the biggest you know Stacy - you
know whatever it is but when I read her
article you know respond to that I
thought that Stacy was too classy I
thought I thought it was too highbrow
she should have been angry at every
black person whether you are a liberal
or they were conservative whether your
left or your right should be outraged
that that woman did that yeah because
it's not only if it's not only offensive
to you your own existence but you're
right it's about the history yeah it's
also why you know I see all the time you
can go and if you look you know I think
there was that stuff someone did a study
that ben shapiro gets more anti-semitic
tweets than like the top ten next people
combined and you know i've mentioned
this many times but I grew up around
Holocaust survivors I knew people that
had the the tattoos on their arms so if
you say some nonsense to me online it
actually has no meaning because I know
my history I know the history of my
people right I know what real pain is
right going through a real genocide
right so it's it's a dismissal of the
history right imagine if someone said
you you're no longer Jewish because you
know what you like this yeah excuse me
yeah excuse me
like how far gone are Hollywood liberals
they think if that's acceptable yeah
here we are in LA and I'm talking about
this yeah can you move to LA yeah
no I don't know I love her yeah all
right what we should talk about the NFL
take it take anything because obviously
that's what everyone's talking about
right what are your what are your
thoughts it's it's it's trending it's
it's ridiculous it's uneducated you know
obviously I would say you know no
offense but I don't really care people
take it offensively athletes aren't the
brightest bulbs right I mean what are we
talking think about because you went to
high school if they mean it like you
know to d1 schools they aren't the
brightest bulbs to begin with half of
them don't even know why they're on
their knees okay it's just literally
trending and it's upsetting to see
another you know purse people you should
have have someone from the NFL talk to
you about why they're taking a knee
Colin Kaepernick is half white he tweets
the most ridiculous things you know I
he started the trend of I don't know if
you know Independence Day you know I'm
not celebrating Independence Day because
you know this country doesn't represent
my peoples you know 50 percent of him he
means right like my people struggle so
he instead spent Independence Day in
Africa do people know their history how
did we get to America how do we get to
America who sold you to to the Americans
you're always say we were kings we were
Queens no we weren't we were slaves and
peasants over there too you know what I
mean people don't know their own history
they think that we literally were kings
and queens okay and white men came over
and and put us in ships and brought us
over that's not the way it worked
does anybody want to live in Africa
right now are you actually upset in the
history of every culture people have
been slaves I don't know why people that
are African or you know African
descendants I should say we're all
American right and I feel that are in
America feel that they have a right to
like some sort of reparation for the
fact you know the fact that slavery
happened it's ridiculous to me and to
think that this was all inspired by
Colin Kaepernick and people are now
being completely disrespectful to the
veterans okay and the people that are
actively in the military do do you know
what that flag means to them you know
they're willing to die for it you are a
millionaire athlete on your knees not
respecting your country it's
anti-american it's disgusting it really
is disgusting so all that being said
you're not you are for them being able
to express that view right you're for
them
I mean I don't want to put words in your
mouth are you HOT for that for them
being on their knees for them being
allowed to do it listen people doesn't
mean there's not gonna be consequence
right that's what I'm saying I should do
it and there should be consequences if
they want to do what they should do it
but this is a job they get paid and
customers are now leaving if you will
okay and this is a capitalist society
fire them fire them I'm happy Colin
didn't get signed yeah interesting so my
position on this is consistent
completely with everything else which is
I believe they can do what they want the
business can do indeed wise the
government as long as they can Trump
unfortunately I think in this case
because I think he has exacerbated the
situation can say whatever he wants
right he can't put a law in place or an
executive action and then you as the fan
can decide if you want to go or not it's
actually the beauty of democracy yeah
that's the video I did this week we're
watching freedom work right it's
upsetting right like there's a lot of
inconsistencies in the way everyone
behaves but freedom's actually working
right now like what am i system would
this be working as well absolutely and I
think the implications here is what
we're really seeing is a preview to 2020
I think that for some reason the
Democrats new platform is like
anti-american like you know yeah like
it's anti-american so let's see how it
works out for them are you fully on
board the Trump train um listen I like
Trump I did not vote for him which is a
common misconception people think I
voted for him nope Alice was falling
down the rabbit hole at that time and I
had to learn I had to relearn everything
it was like having to learn to walk and
talk and everything that you thought was
wasn't and I like Trump because I like
that he's not PC I like that he says
what is on his mind I don't feel like
I'm being sold something you know Barack
Obama was an amazing speaker you can get
in front of a crowd and he can ease them
instantly but at the end of the day he
was a puppet who did absolutely nothing
for the black community I like Trump
because he has financial freedom
I like that Trump is not taking money
from George Soros okay and that means
that there is a chance that we can you
know sort of take out this globalist
environment that has been created and
that is why they attack him so much
because they don't own him so that is
why I support Donald Trump yeah so when
you hear him do you know when some of
the Twitter stuff and all of that other
stuff I mean my feeling I I don't you
know everyone's out
all the time so a tweet something I know
it's stupid right or it's dishonest or
there was a grammatical error or a typo
or whatever and I know everyone goes
crazy about all of it and I've tried not
to care about that stuff too much
because I think it's all a distraction
the media is outraged
they've write articles on the outrage
before anyone has had a chance to get
out yeah all of that nonsense but is
there any element like do you think he's
fully telling the truth all the time I
mean that this is the one piece of the
look I have a lot of Trump supporters
that watch so obviously I think I've
been very fair to him people on the left
many hate me because I've been fair to
him right but do you think there's
anything to the element of just like
just the way this is all going down is
not good
I think the liars are the media I mean I
don't know if everything he says it's
the truth I I'm I'm pretty confident
that he would know better than to lie
when everybody's waiting for him to lie
yeah yeah he couldn't have more hitmen
waiting to take him down to be a really
bad time to tell a lie that I know it's
both he's really good about saying
something that's not quite true and
everyone goes crazy and then there's a
grain of truth everyone's like I see it
was kind of true right and I love that
he tweets cuz you have to understand
that's the only way that he can get the
truth out and that's true no matter what
he says they spin it no matter how he
says that they spin it we saw that with
the Charlottesville think what he said
was factually accurate but they spun it
to this like he's supporting the KKK you
know so it is very important that he
gets behind he tweets because it's how
he won the election well if any you know
if any broken if it ain't broken don't
fix it yeah you know so I think he's
doing the right thing and I think he
understands how he got into the White
House and he knows that no matter what
he does or doesn't do the media's gonna
write a hit piece anyway so go crazy
yeah what do you think about just the
general state of things right now like I
sense sort of like an an interesting
optimism in you yeah yeah all health
seems to be breaking yeah and I'm kind
of isolate like some days I wake up I'm
like man you really like sort of
seemingly at the end of like some
amazing experiment right and then on the
other hand I think there's all these
cool people like you every day that are
getting empowered so like maybe there is
some great chance here right I I think
that there is a tremendous opportunity
here there the media is dying the media
is dying a slow and painful death no one
no one
character they say anymore okay they can
keep pretending and talking to
themselves and laughing at themselves
Hollywood is losing power crazy I don't
know if you noticed but we used to put
CNN on in the green room we now put a
cartoon network it makes a lot more
sense yeah it makes yeah it makes more
sense upon like South Park or something
right look I I nobody trusts the media
anymore and so we're just kind of seeing
what I perceive as like a mental spiral
half of what you know they're saying on
air should be kept between them and
their therapist you know I like I should
I be privy to this like you know like
they're they're spiraling because they
are aware deep down you know that they
are they've lost control people don't
care if they think anymore their
opinions not value people would rather
watch a girl on YouTube who flips open
her laptop and talk about politics okay
then pay attention to an anchor that's
paid by CNN what do you think about that
kind of thing I think it's amazing it's
it means that people are hungry for
truth and it means that people are
waking up it's fascinating
we are we are in an era that is just
absolutely fascinating I'm just so happy
that I get to be a part of it
yeah that's so cool red pill I don't
know what the phrase red pill because I
think it means different things to
different people why did you choose that
well the matrix you know and it was
purely up in the air here Lee off the
matrix I don't know what else it could
mean I know that the left tried to take
in say that it was like um you know yeah
that it somehow means some white
supremacist yeah yeah they're just lying
another hit piece you know you know
another day another hit piece girl yeah
no red pill isn't the true essence of
the matrix which is that once you start
realizing how things actually work right
then you are a red pills individual so
then I started the black because I do
through the black yeah yes again so yeah
and my goal is to wake up people in the
black community because we are the ones
that are being used the most by
Democrats and like you said they have
built the systems that keep us down and
yet we keep supporting them yeah all
right so you're gonna do it we're into
about ten more minutes just the two of
us we're gonna take like a 30-second
break and then you'll take questions
from the good people out there I
absolutely of course with no rules no
rules no rules no live unedited
all right so about ten more minutes so
all right so is anyone on the right
these days doing right by the black
community do you think if it is the
Democratic policies and identity
politics that's that's harming the black
community is anyone on the right
addressing it
properly yeah they're all called Coons
you had Larry elder here yeah you know I
mean there are people that are trying to
educate them they're trying to help the
black community and they're being you
know unfairly labeled and scrutinized by
the media so there are a ton of people
out there they're trying to do the right
thing and a lot of white people but
unfortunately a second you know a white
person tells black people what's
actually happening they make it labeled
white nationalist yeah and the people
won't black people are racist in a way
that they actually won't listen to what
you have to say if you're if you're
white they just assume that you know
they have the upper hand in the
conversation you know because that's
what the left has taught them and it's
all white privilege and just know what
he means he doesn't know what he's
saying
so dismiss that means white supremacists
are you shocked how quickly the white
supremacist meme got out there like it
actually does show success I think in
sort of that what I've been fighting
against for these last couple years
because I kept mocking the words bigoted
and racist right because this is
nonsense what you guys are doing so I
almost feel like they've thrown those
words out yeah you don't hear any what's
called a bigot anymore I barely hear
they're called a racist right now
they're white surprise everyone so we've
like actually it does show that in a way
we've like shifted this thing
yeah we're what's next yeah we go yeah I
don't know yeah I don't know what could
possibly be next I really don't know you
know they're sucking the fun of
everything like I said and that you know
somebody's dying to go back to the NFL
thing it's just like Jesus they the left
I don't know if they sit around a table
and come up with what else can we take
the sign of you know what I mean like
what else can we take the fine if that's
what it feels like right like you don't
want to watch football you don't want to
watch award shows anymore it's
everything is about politics everyone
wants to be a hero and say something for
five seconds have an applause in their
own echo chamber yeah you're so right
you know even the Emmys last week I
every other year in the last 5 or 7
years probably I live-tweeted them who
cares this year I was just saying I just
don't want to deal with politics on a
Sunday Mary its wife and I didn't watch
any football I'm not even the biggest
football fan but on a normal Sunday yeah
I'll just flick around a couple games I
was like watching it you know cuz
they're there sucking the fun out of
everything with all of this virtue
signaling you know and I don't know
what's next
Disneyland you know you're gonna call
Mia and Mickey's gonna be kneeling down
differencing in what's going on here and
toddlers gonna be crying and they're
gonna explain that you know I would what
do you think that's about that sort of
like sucking of fun
because I do think there's a reason
there's a reason the fun suck I think
there is a reason if they can keep you
miserable although yeah and keep you
guilty all the - yeah you're very easily
manipulated
yeah it's brainwash it's it's it's a
system of mass brainwash obviously but
it's not working and that I am I don't
know if I'm overly optimistic but I'm
extremely optimistic because you and I
are sitting here having this
conversation because you know I was just
at the daily wire earlier today and
their studio their office space is
growing wrong it's fast and because the
conservative movement is growing because
people are realizing that there's
nothing left for them left yeah you
either want to race towards the bottom
if that's what it is right it's I'm a
bigger victim I'm a bigger victim I'm a
bigger victim I'm a bigger I'm like what
do we you guys racing let's do this you
know what I mean
and that people get sick of it it's a
constant state of misery yeah you know
yet it works to a certain certain crew
you think this is all about education
period like at the end yeah I've started
to really come around to that I you know
it's sort of cliche sometimes when
you're like oh education is the answer
to everything right but like the basic
even just in the last couple weeks I got
into something with an old friend of
mine who I've recently reconnected with
and was saying all this sort of we not
outright calling me a racist or a bigot
but it was all like right there and I
really just wanted to be like you don't
know anything about political philosophy
or what the foundations of a government
are already you know and I just kind of
I've gotten pretty good at like yes just
getting rid of these conversations and
make sure it doesn't escalate so I kind
of let it go but that's what I left with
like if you don't understand what rights
are right what the purpose of the
society is owning your own mental
capacity and all that stuff you're gonna
fall for any of this thing well listen
let's call it what it is the majority of
people from an IQ standpoint are stupid
so that mean that's that's the cool
that's you know it's true I mean
factually speaking like 84 you know 80%
of people I don't know what the IQ range
is but they're just they're actually not
that intelligent right so that has been
kind of the leftist like okay well let's
just feed them stuff they're not smart
enough to think through it and they'll
fall for it and so it's very easy to
manipulate them and they're just being
brainwashed yeah man yeah I feel like we
should jump into the questions because I
feel like people are gonna have a
gajillion questions for you did I
anything here I feel like not good no
right yeah yeah all right so here's what
I do give me I said 30 seconds maybe one
minute you want one minute one minute
and one minute people 60 seconds we'll
be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys we're back we are live on
YouTube and Facebook I am here with
Candice aka red pill black people seem
to like you did you know that I hope so
they dig what you're doing
alright so here's what we're gonna take
questions on patreon so if you are a
patreon member you can just comment in
the video box right there so we've got a
bunch of questions there we're also
gonna do the super chat thing on YouTube
so depending on how much you give it
bumps your question up and has a better
chance that I will see it here we're
getting all this live Candice said to me
right during the break there are no
rules so here we go it will start with
super chat using the current trending
hashtag take any controversy do you feel
the media's focus on the problems in the
black community is helpful or just
exploitation for their own agenda and
doing more harm in the long run the
media is not focused on issues in the
black community at all the issues in the
black community or not the national
anthem so you know your question
basically say the issues are pretty I
talk about prison reform we have to talk
about education we have to talk about
fathers you know getting the black
families back together how much this do
you think is about the the family thing
because I see conservatives talk about a
lot and years ago if you would have
asked me it would have been like this is
eye off the ball stuff and now I do see
it differently it's so much I mean you
have no idea what it means you know not
to come up with a father figure you know
in these black communities people are
raising themselves kids are raising kids
you know so there are a lot of things
written into that I'm passionate I do
I'm literally doing a charity event on
Sunday for father absence I'm nice what
sympathies do you have with the blue
pills in their positions that's a good
one yeah I love that question I have a
lot of sympathy because I was one of
them you know I understand how easy it
is to get brainwash because it's written
in to our DNA from the time we're in
like kindergarten okay until you finish
college so I know that it's they're not
being willfully ignorant they just don't
know any other way I'm hoping that I'll
be able to guide them yeah are there any
leftist things that you have sympathy
for or think they might be doing better
than the Conservatives or anything right
now no yeah sorry
alright just wanted to know what you
think is the truth okay
I would love to see a brief exploration
of whether classical liberalism would
naturally be the path of black Americans
if the Democratic Party had not co-opted
the process of freeing us all from
bigotry in America it's a great question
because I think that most minority
communities in general would completely
identify with true class of course they
would they did you know of course I know
it's just it's not here
thoughts on the surveillance state
what's that you know that the NSA in
spying oh yeah I 1,008 do I think it
what thoughts in what terms I mean do
you think it's necessary or I definitely
I don't know I don't know how to take an
I don't know yeah I don't want to I
don't want to say something without
being you know completely educated on
the topics and I don't some of these
things that people always say is it a
necessary evil you know and I don't
really know yeah it's funny how
everyone's gonna suddenly want you to
know everything yeah you're like I
created YouTube yeah I grew pretty quick
not to know everything yeah yeah yeah I
don't really know and we discuss on that
right now yeah wasn't social autopsy
really shut down because trolls from
4chan and kiwi farms exposed security
flaws and showed it's a doctor's dream
so some of that's going a little over my
head um I can answer the question yes
but you have to remember that Zoey was
she was running that she was she told me
that she was on 4chan all of this stuff
so it's they were the ones that were
inundating kickstarter and calling them
kicks are never gave me an explanation
for it they just said that it was pulled
because it went against their policies
but they never you know indicated which
policy it was yeah I mean your story I
almost think not that I like to bring
the law into a lot of these things but
really in a way she was extorting you
yeah
is what she was doing yeah you had a
subtle conversation where she said if
you don't do this right it's sort of
what CN ended with that me mate yeah
remember yeah if you do this thing again
yeah I'm gonna release your yeah yeah
really did the same yeah kind of shoes
but she did it behind anonymous troll so
it's ever you know oh just the worst
okay all right this is kind of long run
so bear with me I this is from patreon I
have trouble reconciling
a lot of trumps policies is outright
racist or outright discriminatory and
the reaction from the fringe left
activists has been enlightening to say
the least about how fractured the party
is is the net effect of this socio
political debacle a reformed more
rational rational accountable left or
the formation of an independent party
that manages to actually satisfy the
needs of both sides of the aisle I'm
thinking bernie & johnson supporter so i
think basically what they're saying is
is there any chance that the moderates
that are left on the left whoever they
are can they fix this or is this is it
just too late it's too late I think any
moderate that's on the left is going to
end up going to the right you know
unfixable yeah yeah I tried yeah do you
believe the war on drugs
disproportionately affects the black
community yes I do believe the war on
drugs disproportionately affects the
black community yeah so that might be
somewhere where you'd have sympathy yes
with a leftist position because that the
left is more focused on reforming right
prisons right maybe not doing in the
right way but they are more focused on
the right and I take a lot of issue with
the war on drugs period you know I just
think that it's an illness and we're not
addressing it the right way putting
people in prison that are addicted to
drugs it's just you know it's beyond me
when people you know they're not
themselves and yeah I have a lot of
thoughts on that but I agree yeah it's
true so crazy I mean obviously we're
here in California where it's
medicinally legal and I guess as of next
calendar year it'll be recreational
legal but that I used to have in New
York I get weed and that could be a
crime we're here I can literally walk
two blocks away when we walk out of here
and I can get a joint yeah at a store
yeah it's ridiculous yeah it's pretty
nuts okay super chat so much of the
black brainwashing takes place in black
churches once that's baked in from
childhood can the liberal stranglehold
on the black mind to be broken and
messed that's interesting do you think
that there's a connection to like a
political it is a ssin of churches I
really don't know not religious at all
so it's hard for me I always try to like
you know pull from my personal
experiences when I consider these
questions but I really don't know I
don't go to church so okay super Chad's
school choice abolishing the minimum
wage in deregulating venture enter
prai's would do more for the black
community than any welfare program yep
the black community has become subject
to the state I mean this is elder stuff
absolutely I agree so how do you do that
though I know you're not a policy but
like so if you've had a group of people
forgetting color but you've got any
group of people on welfare for so long
how do you just flip the switch cuz you
you do it did you do it you just do it
okay put their backs against a wall and
watch people fight okay people are not
gonna say oh well it's gone I guess I'm
never gonna eat ever again you know
people this is the problem is that
they've become rely on you know relying
on it because it's there you know what
I'm saying if it's not there they were
calm with other solutions that is that's
called being a human being we are
naturally survivors well said all right
let's jump over to Facebook let us know
how to support her so they wanted how to
support you we'll get to that and I want
to see you stick around and continue to
do your work great interview how can
people support you I'm on patreon so if
I can siphon money from you on Realtree
on yeah if you're donating red pill
black yeah okay what do you think about
millions of young Americans on
psychiatric drugs is the reason that so
many are bein brainwashed again I know
you're not an expert in some of this
stuff I'm sorry can you repeat that so
many young Americans are on some
psychiatric drugs don't even know I I
have I am passionately against
psychiatric drugs passionately I mean if
if people are and I when I say that I
mean that we are just over prescribed
it's unbelievable your kid can't focus
so he's got 80s you give him a pill
maybe he's not interested in reading a
math book you know playing you know what
I mean like it's that's not the focus
it's your focus on what you care about
you know if you're interested in
something you're gonna be focused on it
naturally so a lot of that stuff it
scares me yeah that there and there's
the age is just going down and down and
down in terms of what they're willing to
give children I mean that is like a
scary and a whole other topic
you know xanax to combat sadness which
is like a natural state of being a human
being you know you're sad sometimes
you're happy sometimes and you know my
friend puts me really well in college
she said if you can answer the question
as to why you're sad you don't need a
pill if you're just if mean you're
sitting here right now ice break down
crying for no reason something I feel it
wrong you know maybe some of you knows
some about you know something going on
there that I need to like consult a
psychiatrist about if I'm crying
you know hysterically and under my
covers because my mom died okay I don't
need a xanax pill I have to deal with
being a human being you know so you know
how that stuff it's so obvious to me how
it affects the brain now I'm not saying
there aren't legit reasons to be on some
of that stuff for sure and it's not a
matter of people need a certain amount
of help right but for there was about a
six month period when I was on one of
those I don't remember what it was
called like celexa or something I don't
know about six months and a friend of
mine died a very good friend of mine
from childhood and I was with my whole
family we all were very very close with
him and everyone else was hysterical
crying and I felt nothing that's that's
exactly what it does to people it
doesn't make you feel happy doesn't make
you feel sad it just makes you exist
yeah that's terrifying and then I I
literally so you know what they tell you
to get off these things you should the
way you're supposed to do it is you'd
wean yourself off like maybe every other
day then every other third day or
whatever it is I just went off I just
didn't know that and I was just like I'm
not taking this anymore I'm not even
telling the doctor bla bla bla my brain
about two weeks later I could you know
when used to turn on an old computer and
you'd hear like whirring and buzzing
like I literally was hearing that in my
brain my brain was like restart yeah
it's terrifying yeah pharmaceutical
that's a huge issue in a platform that
people should be talking about whole
other thing
superjet how would you reform the prison
how would I know yeah you know how I
reform that not the president United
States I'm open to having you know a
discussion and seeing what somebody
would present as a means to you know
reform per system first off stop
arresting people for things they don't
need to be in prison for okay like you
know we don't need somebody you know to
be in prison because it's just
three-strikes-you're-out policy over you
know smoking a joint or anything like
that so a lot of that starts with just
actually looking at the reasons people
actually go to prison I think would be a
launchpad but there's this a lot going
on there I'd have to really speak to
people in prison and understand it
better and I'm not there just yet yeah I
have a feeling you're gonna be involved
in all of these Congress yeah I would
muster yeah you know all my uncle's
prison locked up you know visiting my
uncle in prison growing up it's you know
so that's a big part of being black in
America I'm sure Chelsea will say you
know doesn't matter you get that dog
away
all right super chat Candace I know
you're from Dallas I grew up there and
later Austin I have lived in San
Francisco for the last 12 years your
opinions of Dallas and that of the Bay
Area if you've ever visited I'm not from
Dallas yeah wrong wrong red pill black
maybe red pill why red pill white or red
pill well are you I think you were just
saying you were just up in San Francisco
that is the yeah that was like full time
of lunacy yeah um i sat under an empathy
tent something I would maybe see at a
preschool it was in the middle of the
square like their main square I can't
think of the name of it is there was an
empathy tent but there what's going on
groan oh you know I went right in there
I was like hey what's going on here you
know can I sit there like yeah we just
talk about our feelings I'm like I'm
like really we've got a problem you know
we're starting to it's college campus
thing is it's getting a little bizarre
these are adults these are grown men I
mean these are like you know older than
you like I mean this was they were like
grown men sitting under there saying I
was like why'd you guys launch this you
know they're like you know Barack Obama
gave a speech saying that you know we
need more empathy so we made it 10 like
I like how you just went ages they're
older than you you old bastard she was
pointing to the great white beard do you
think that police action like stop in
search where black people are more
frequently checked is racist or logical
based on statistics of crime for example
in the UK black men are more likely to
carry knives but stop and search was
cancelled as it predominantly targeted
black youths so it's a good question
because this is one of the ones where
they see that it generally does work
we're in crime and there could be a
racial element right and some people
would argue they're overtly yeah yeah I
don't think that it was intended to be
racist and as you saw that there were
like I said there were there were
positive effects to it because it is
real but just imagine the other side of
that which is being a black person
getting stopped for no reason other than
the fact that you're black like that's
not that's not cool we can't just walk
down the street and be like well no in
this area black people normally do this
and because you're black we're going to
stop
you so I can see it's it's it's
violating that it's it doesn't feel good
to just be you know could be you because
you're black yes it is true what he's
talking about from a statistical
standpoint black people do commit you
know these crimes and that's something I
can't be ignored but I'm not sure that
like creating you know a policy of
profiling based off of that really works
yeah yeah
cuz like I would be really upset if I
just got like stopped because I was
black you know thank you are you kidding
me I mean a year ago when I lived in
West Hollywood which is pretty white
area pretty uppity or whatever I was I
was literally pulled over about looking
for parking outside of my house I was
just trying to park and whatever and I
got out it turned out that it was
obviously the officer was training a
younger guy and was just trying to like
show him the ropes a little bit and he
asked me how much I had drank I
literally did have one glass of wine at
a friend's before he had me blow the
breathalyzer you don't have to follow a
light looking all this stand on one foot
and I was nervous even though I knew I
wasn't drunk and doing anything illegal
I was right in front of my eyes but I
was nervous but I did think in that
moment out because I haven't been pulled
over by a cop besides that and I did
think in that moment how quickly these
things could escalate well yeah the
slope to slippery slope I mean imagine
if we're like hey you know it turns out
that majority people that have duis or
are white males so we're just gonna be
stopping white males yeah you know
you're white male so you get stopped
it's like what like yeah and also I'm a
little dyslexic and when he had me do
the he wanted me to follow a life but
not move my head so I could just move my
eyes like this but my head just kind of
kept moving it's like a little bit of a
jump rope right yeah yeah and just I
could see how if I was a little more
hostile if he was very actually racist
right you're instantly going to be
hostile if you're getting stopped for
doing nothing yeah yeah all right super
chat dear Candace will you be in Europe
and if so will you go to lunch with me
sure I love lunch I love food and I love
Europe there you go what do you think
this super chat again what do you think
of Planned Parenthood killing black
unborn babies and limiting the black
population and why do black
conservatives look hot how about we'll
deal with why are black conservatives
hot black conservatives are hot because
conservative women tend to not prescribe
to feminism and feminism teaches you
that if you're fat it's their fault not
yours you shouldn't have to try to look
nice ever just be a fat slob and it's
everybody else's fault not yours the
world's broken not you girl ironically
that was the least controversial part of
the question here the first part about
Planned Parenthood been yeah I agree
Planned Parenthood and that's why I said
I I definitely am trying to really for
my pains on abortion but I
I hate Planned Parenthood and it's it's
1,000 century and the locations are in
these poorer communities and it was
literally built for the purpose and it
served his purpose you know it has
decreased the black population by a lot
so so where you at on abortion in
general I know you're I'm gonna wait
before I I'm ready to talk about where I
stand on that because I don't want to
back myself into a corner and not be
able to backpedal while I'm still you
know yeah but I have a lot of comment
range to the people and I am careful not
to take a position but when I do it'll
be a firm one yeah it's one of those
ones where I think you can have a
totally principled position from both
sides right so I happen to be pro-choice
I've heard been Shapiro's arguments on
pro-life sitting in that very chair I
think they're perfectly principled and
that's what being an American is all
about right we're gonna disagree on
these writings and I mean I just I think
it was like marketing even like I think
abortion is really just about population
control you know like you know so I
don't I don't I don't really buy into
this whole it's about pro-choice it's
just what they've convinced you it's
about pro-choice you know that's some
serious red pill right she's snorting
the red bow
alright guys reminder what are we doing
here we're taking questions with Candice
on patreon it's all loaded right in the
chat right there and on super chat we'll
take a couple on Facebook as well let's
roll well a few people that's something
to this effect black on black crime how
do you address it I mean first off
address it right get off your knees in
the football field talking about the
national anthem and let's talk about the
south side of Chicago you know let's
draw attention to real black issues
let's stop pretending it's the police
and this don't shoot movement when like
no black people die at the hands of
police statistically speaking every year
and we're slaughtering ourselves you
know it's insane it's absolutely insane
and I think the first
part is actually addressing it but
people stop pretending that the biggest
threat to the black community are the
KKK in Charlottesville or you know white
police officers shooting black people we
have to actually talk about the issues
first before we can come up with
solutions is the inherent problem though
that the cries of racism and bigotry and
all that have just effectively silenced
the people that should be allies yes
you know you mean like some people that
are just like I don't even want to deal
with this right so I'm just not gonna
say anything right absolutely absolutely
yeah you got to work on those people
yeah get movin
how did Candis see the light slash what
opened her eyes to the truth you already
addressed that so we'll let that one go
patreon are you equally as scared of the
language morphing process we have to
dance around concerning groups like an
tyfa I have friends who believe they're
actually anti-fascists despite their
actions directly conflicting with the
concept of fascism many of my friends
buy into the rhetoric and buzzwords used
to prescribe their political enemies
words like feminism equality racism and
privilege seem to have been toxically
infected with the definitions that make
conversations about these issues even
more touchy this is this whole question
yeah I think we're talking but what do
you think about that just the words the
way we're using words that's lot these
days it's sloppy they don't even realize
it's counter well in most situations
which he mentioned it's counterintuitive
to everything that the movement was
represented right well it classically
remembers his liberals and classic
feminism versus what feminism is today
these movements have been hijacked and
people don't realize it because they
really don't even know how these
movements started they don't really know
history at all you know they just think
they're doing something it feels good
because CNN tells them they're doing the
right thing you know which is amazing to
see you know Trevor Noah
be outraged be outraged you know no one
sees Trevor now when the audience at
black-letter protests know he's walking
around New York you know swanky
penthouse you know the puppet the puppet
you know it okay yeah yeah well that's
the thing for me I just hate how it's
killed comedy yeah I just hate how these
people are just screaming all day long
and they don't care now about evidence I
saw that all of these people last week
with Betsy DeVos flipping the title 9
thing yeah and and all these comedians
screaming about how Trump's
rape and they're all pro rape it's like
actually title nine the way it was being
instituted was actually harming right
young men who were completely innocent
and was creating a way around due
process and against the cousin yep you
can't get you can't they just like I
said they're just not educated and like
you said it's killed comedy nothing's
funny anymore I don't know how many
times they can say the same joke before
they realize that only they and their
friends are laughing
and yeah yeah they're gonna kill comedy
kill kill sports and then everyone will
be tuning into you on YouTube yes fine
it'll work it's not that you have a
favorite book I always I mean I read a
lot I don't know if I have a favorite
book
nothing favorite all right I'll take it
you did sort answer this one but maybe
you can go on it a little bit more do
you think there is a bigotry of low
expectations of course there's a bigotry
of low expectations they somehow
convinced the african-american community
black community whatever you want to
call it to argue you know to say that
they need help we need help no no don't
take that away we can't do it by
ourselves there's no way we can do it by
ourselves you take that away we'll have
nothing that's so sad it's sad to me
that they don't think that they can make
it on their own you know and that is the
bigotry of low expectations and again
all we have to do is inject a little bit
of Education because when you actually
sit down and teach them most people at
our on section II have bigger fish to
fry then you know like they'd actually
don't even know what they're accepting
when they take it they just know that
they're pregnant they're gonna have a
baby and they have mouths to feed
right and this person's gonna give them
a check that's the extent of their
knowledge in terms of what they're
accepting and people need to actually
explain to them there's no one explained
some what section eight is that section
eight do you understand the implications
here it's not something you want to be
on is something that is going to be
generational but it encourages you not
to get married encourage you to have
more children you know and you can never
have more you know it's just you're just
always under so again start centers
education why does it feel like the race
discussion are boiled down to white
versus black while Hispanics were only
mentioned when it comes to immigration
and Asians are out of the conversation
entirely by the left that is a great
question they also do a mic only person
that knows like mixed kids
these poor people are like what the hell
am I gonna do I'm f white half black I'm
half Spanish my the only person like
again again it's Candace Owens in a
bubble my only person has tons of
friends that are mixed yeah it's a joke
you know they literally you have boiled
it down to there's only white or black
pick one yeah it's crazy it's delusional
do you buy what I was saying earlier
about the Asian community yeah that's
the next one for the whole turn on it
has to be has to be you're right they
they go after it they they are they're
doing too well yeah they're doing to us
you can take them down and the more sort
of the more of this fake diversity stuff
that you force through who's it gonna
hurt it's actually gonna hurt the Asian
right the agents that are working hard
yeah that deserved the same equality
right everybody else deserves what do
you think of affirmative action I think
I know your answer already but is there
any merit to any of it no no get rid of
it
don't no absolutely not I think that
there are things that if we're talking
about just letting someone into a school
because they're black affirmative action
you know there are definitely things
that I think would be great in terms of
establishing more scholarships for black
people or encouraging them and again a
lot of the stuff starts at home these
kids go to school in high school tired
because they're raising their baby
sister when they're moms you know trying
to work at night that's really what goes
on in black communities affirmative
action it's an insult it's an insult I
can't get in base my own merit we have
all the resources to get in based off of
our own merit we don't need help and
also by the way it's counterintuitive to
capitalism affirmative action it doesn't
even make sense like imagine if like we
just started hiring people based off of
like political correctness like removing
three black guys you know he's not the
smartest guy here at Goldman Sachs but
there's a global market happening we
hire the best the best the best the best
that's the best well I always think of
it in terms of like think about it just
in terms of a doctor or airline pilot
they don't think about it just in terms
of you're right
yeah ditch-digger although perfectly
nice guy too but like can you imagine
your doctor at the end of the day
forgetting race yeah do you want your
doctor to be the best educated yeah and
most equipped to deal with the surgery
you're gonna deal with or do you want
somebody that's skated by perfect
analogy technology yeah I know you
admire Kanye West do you think that
Kanye will be
speaking out for the truth anytime soon
or has he been threatened into
submission before you answer that
question I will tell you although I
can't tell everyone where we are right
now
I do see Kanye often somewhere very near
where we are right now that's all I can
say maybe I can work a little something
oh my gosh I'm only a fan people asking
who are you fan of you know I'm only a
fan of Kanye West and the interesting
thing is a popular Kanye quote is that
if you're a fan of Kanye West you're not
really a fan of Kanye West you're a fan
of yourself and you believe that you you
can make it and his whole brand yeah his
whole brand and most people who don't
like Kanye West don't follow his music
so he doesn't make they take he's an
[ __ ] and it's an arrogant [ __ ] and
what he actually is preaching is holding
on to your own ideas holding on to you
the version that you are the version
that you were when you came into this
world before you know school we sort of
stripped you down and made you think
that you couldn't do it but what we're
talking about right low applications for
everyone black white Spanish that's what
you learn in school but you got to go
work for somebody you got to do this on
the SATs you got to be interested in
math science maybe you're not good at
that maybe you're only good at this so
his his whole brand is what I love it's
about just believing in yourself like to
the umpteenth degree you know to the
point of almost illusion being stepping
into your own world and being in your
own mind and not allowing people to
taint that I remember the question I
think the question basically was do you
think you can kind of go all the way
yeah like in terms of what you're
talking about
yeah political level like yeah the stuff
that you're really good yeah so you can
get there cuz he kind of yeah Johnson
Betsey Johnson and the problem with
Kanye is he gets misunderstood and he's
not the most eloquent speaker you know
who coquilles he'll rant and then he'll
say one thing and go over here and
people that don't follow him don't dig
deep enough yeah but I mean Kanye what
he could do for the Black Moon and he
tried it you know he told them a high
supported on top and look what happened
to mental disorder
did you check it yeah yeah yeah people
were like hey I only said that because
he has a mental disorder and he
purposely only checked out what did he
do he went straight to trunk Tower and
did a photo op with Donald Trump's white
people essentially no that wasn't an
ugly sweater I said what I said and I
meant it you know and it's because he's
always been anti PC people look back at
that Taylor moment and don't realize
what he was saying was true you know she
didn't deserve the award
there's really people that follow music
it was it's outrageous that she won that
award but it was about you know
pleasing certain fanbase whatever it was
it was totally like you know hijacked
and he did it again not the most
allocated I mean that doesn't really
think through a that's the axe and
afterwards like ammunition done it that
way but what he was saying was
incredibly important important he's
always been anti PC yeah it's funny I
don't even remember I know that I
remember that moment I was watching it
but I didn't know a lot about who they
think should have won it was and she won
for like a fairytale princess like dress
up it was right so I I'm not that's like
not really my music so I don't know I
didn't really care about that but I
remember watching anything what a dick
he was but understanding it the way
you're framing it yeah cuz people don't
follow music so that's what I said it's
very hard for people to understand Kanye
West or to be fascinated by him or to
understand that I first said if you
understand Kanye West and you can
understand the movement of Donald Trump
like it's funny to me that people can't
correlate that it's very similar it's
just anti political correctness you know
really interesting all right from super
chat what do you think of the regressive
left coined by Maajid Nawaz also Sam
Harris for president if Sam runs I will
vote for him I think we got your sense
I'm with ya the regressive all right you
know what I think we're do we're do a
couple more you want to get a drink
after this yeah maybe we'll go hunt down
can do a couple more and then we're
gonna get a big deer can't is taking
positives from the negatives do you
think that hollywood's leftist rhetoric
is going to push people away from
cinemas and perhaps into more creative
pursuits plus you're super pretty
thank you for comment yes i think
hollywood is a sinking ship they either
gotta shut up and do what they do
we want to see them act and sing bad you
know that's it you know i said in a
video but the extent of me watching a
VMAs like the dumbest reasons that why
do I don't care about what your personal
opinions are and stop speaking down to
the rest of the world you know so yeah I
think they're a sinking ship I don't
know what other creative fields well
YouTube and just do your own thing yeah
do your own thing ya know it's funny I
always think it so funny like people
want to get their morals from Hollywood
or morals from sports yeah if that's
just an industry yeah we'll be like
saying I want to get my morals from the
garbage yeah yeah it makes
no that just doesn't make sense yeah
they're true they have a product yes
they want people to buy exactly their
morals from Hollywood I gotta get my
morals from the pet industry sorry
cohort as a black conservative are you
ready to experience black on black
racism on Candace which is a hilarious
display of racism on Kendall odd Candace
Candace yeah yeah I mean I see a couple
of that'd sure I don't my vlog series
the myths of the [ __ ] for a reason you
know it's a myth I don't care call me a
[ __ ] call me a Uncle Tom auntie Tom aunt
Candace whatever you need to call me
that makes you feel good I'm not gonna
stop you know I'm here to stay
this is a good one I'm glad someone's
addressing us I should have mentioned
before can you describe any efforts to
control your message you've experienced
from YouTube Twitter etc it's
interesting because it's an alarming
trend so I've talked a lot about it
obviously you mentioned with zoe
involved in twitter already have you
seen anything that you can really point
to as i was censored on youtube they
pulled my video for no reason I don't
know what that was the black lives
matters list of demands for white people
I read her list the girl who wrote the
list out loud and I kind of like you
know point of the fact that it kind of
sounded like Veruca Salt don't care how
I want it now it was a very like funny
light-hearted video yeah
and as soon as we like cross like
200,000 views YouTube pulled it and said
that for bullying like you know like and
I kind of create a firestorm on Twitter
and it got reestablished Facebook pulls
a post like every other day on even know
what they're pulling anymore a half the
times like okay I'm locked out of my
account gotta get it back in do you
understand our policies like these are
my videos I don't even curse in my
videos like you know what I mean so of
course they're in it together we
understand that they came out and
instead we're going to start censoring
you know or helping bully it's all about
the bullying okay that's that's all
about diversity yeah we were to use
their [ __ ] against them
yeah can we use some of that diversity
yeah yeah exactly so it's interesting
I'm a top of the progressive stack they
don't want to hear me speak so all right
all right will do will do three more and
then we're going patreon do you believe
there's an inherent systemic racism um
no no in in this day and age no absolute
up there's not
it's been how would you define systemic
meaning laws yeah yeah we can do
whatever we want we have all the
resources to do whatever we want we can
build companies there's nothing that is
keeping there's no law that has stopped
me from doing anything that I want in my
life right now
so now fair enough all right two more
and by the way will you stick around
we'll do a rapid fire yeah patreon
exclusive with you all right cool
between the super chat between the core
principles of democracy and
republicanism which do you subscribe to
most is it better to abandon a movement
once it's been hijacked or do everything
you can take it back I think the second
half of that is more interesting because
I think we're both sort in the
transition like right I tried I really
did try yeah no I just don't believe in
what the modern leftist yeah you can't
you have to just jump ship it's
especially right now it's just
absolutely insane I mean there's no way
you one person a hundred of you couldn't
do it you know yeah are you getting any
outreach from people on the left going I
kind of get it or is it yeah actually I
have fans that inbox me and say you know
I would love to have someone to speak to
I feel like this is getting crazy and my
friends are you know getting
increasingly you know more terrifying
and I take time I seek with them it's a
big part of who I am before I go to bed
I just get on Facebook and I'll answer
them and I'll try to guide them a lot of
younger people which is interesting you
know black people in college saying like
they feel like they can't speak up so
definitely yeah cool all right last one
I feel this is appropriate hey where can
I get those shoes girl you can get those
from made well made well yeah all right
you feel good hey but yeah they should
they should give me something for that I
just did a nice plug as well great
report check yeah man all right all
right thank you so much all right man
this and I are gonna go find Kanye West
but if you want more with her we're
gonna do a patreon exclusive rapid-fire
which will be it's exclusive so it'll be
on patreon only I thank you I mean you
read so obvious to me you're gonna be
like a rising star in this space and we
need allies wherever they are absolutely
thank you for having me clear you're
clear and like you're saying your truth
I love it thank you so much I'm
absolutely honored to be here yeah cool
awesome
all right so we're gonna do that and
then we're
if you see anything weird about Kanye in
the news tonight it was probably uh wow
that's pretty fish scales men's it's me
all right thanks for watching
[Music]
you